[Music]
so I wanted to ask you of all the many
many things of the hundreds and
thousands of things that you could do
with your time how did you get exposed
to coding and and walk me through your
yeah first experience or experiences
with that well I love the way that you
you explain it as language and that's
really what it is and I think that like
any language it's a medium that you can
express yourself that you can express
creative ideas and that is what I why I
think it's so powerful I got exposed to
it because I'm just a super curious like
annoying like her curious person I ask a
lot of questions and I love
understanding how things work
I love understanding like how the world
around me works and and how science and
math can be ways to explain that I but I
work in a really creative industry and
and I I don't know I guess I at a
certain point in a couple of years ago I
wanted to understand what code was it
was the term that kept me here did it
was it a person a conversation yeah I
mean I was meeting a lot of
entrepreneurs I was watching the entire
world especially fashion and and media
be transformed by technology and I was
like what is it that a handful of people
who are engineers and building huge
enterprise value what is the secret
language that they know that the rest of
us don't and code and I was like what is
code and how can I learn it so I took a
bootcamp I took one one week and even in
where was it in New York at the Flatiron
school who introduced you to them um
this guy obviously um and he's a great
teacher and he started the school and he
taught me Ruby similar exactly is you
know so like it's a very intuitive kind
of language and and even in a short time
I was able to kind of understand
high-level big principles and the fact
that you can
use code to you know write a line of
code that performs a function and you
can build you can build ideas using this
language and that to me it was just so
mind-blowing to understand like how the
tech that we touch everyday how it works
and to take it one step further but to
actually be able to to write it yourself
and to express your ideas and to be able
to I mean you're a man of your so
efficient Tim it's really inspiring
you're so organizing so you finish it
I'm organized for maybe like two hours
of difference that you're seeing my two
hours if you are it's impressive and I
just think that like even you can build
tech to enable that and and to scale
that and that's what's so powerful is
the ability to scale ideas or scale
problem solving using code and and I
think that there's so much opportunity
that has yet to really even be built in
this kind of intersection of kind of
many intersections of kind of creative
industries with from the perspective of
someone writing code who has different
life experiences or passions maybe then
then most engineers sitting in Silicon
Valley today and and you take this class
yeah you learn the basics of Ruby mm-hmm
with avi without me and how does that
what is code with classy so code is
classy okay folks we the kao de is my
organization where we teach girls to
learn how to code and empower the next
generation of tech leaders so we do that
by running summer camps across the
country and we teach girls the ABCs so
Ruby HTML Javascript CSS enough to be
able to build something so our camps are
across the country and they're two weeks
long and they're totally free and we
have these amazing girls who come into
our our camps and learn these skills and
it's amazing what they're able to build
and not only just the way that they're
able to build their idea
but what they're passionate about so if
it's like making social impact helping
their community but they are able to
build something and recognize the impact
that they can have and that's really
empowering and that's that that for a
girl who's kind of you know at that
point in life where you're like figuring
out what you think you can be or what
you think you can't like that's really
empowering
you